it's a very simple art isn't it you
just need a pair of scissors some
pieces of paper and a little glue and
you can do something
you can express yourself in my case i
meet stories
[Music]
my name is and rosa I'm
83 years old I started cutting in
1969 so fifty years ago
it's paper that we cut and
glue it's a very simple folk art
that  'we find them ten centuries ago
in European countries but also
in Africa
I do it in color a lot of
black and white cuts my paintings
over time have become a bit expensive
average price let's say only
4400 pounds but there are some  to whom are
much more expensive this painting if it is
in the first that I made is that
I offered to my husband 50 years ago
the time passed very quickly
but that you still pleased
what  your memories here
then to make a cutout of a
fault pair of scissors there are
also other techniques  who has the laser and the
cutter, there is also the earth plot, I
only cut on August 6 and
tweezers to take the small
parts and white glue,
you were going to have a very small game, can I cut
out characters who have a centimeter
for my work, I  think it's
the most important color these papers
it gives me ideas i always have
the imagination i had to go to paris to
look for gold because all the
different backgrounds it can take me
a week and this  could also take me
three weeks I have
reproduced houses there is always obviously
the desire in the mountains
[Music]
there is this one this is a big party
where the peasants came down from the
mountain pastures trees that turn red it
really becomes  autumnal i would have
done some this year i think around
fifty i exhibited in geneva i
exhibited a lot in zurich a lot of
times in new york twice me what
interests me is to tell a
story and that people  s be happy
to see this story
yesterday my work
[Music]